like so much foliage reduction Shawn and
thanks for having me it's great being
here and I look forward to discussions
we're gonna have today for today so this
talk is about interactive materials and
to get started just have a look around
you here or have a look at the objects
and photos that you see or in the slide
and I bet you can't but notice that the
materials that surround us are really
rich in versatile styling from say warm
wood moving to hearthstone soft paper
there's a rich variety of materials that
we are surrounded by interacting with on
everyday basis now these objects have
many different geometries most I'm
actually not planar they can be curved
they can be having irregular surface
features they can even integrate fine
features like the example on the upper
left-hand side the human human body and
those objects and materials have very
interesting material properties too so
it can be soft foldable many of them are
even stretchable and of course there's
more to just name a few examples so it's
rich in versatile and the importance of
these materials and shapes has been
recognized at long ago the importance
for the way we interact with our
environment and interact with computing
devices shapes and materials are rooted
in the concept of affordances that we
teach all our students it's also the
COFF tangible interfaces and very
recently members of design community
I've been postulating there's something
like a material turn in contrast if you
don't ever look at the devices that our
professional community is building today
they're very often look like this
example here now is to start embedding
interfaces inside the environment but we
end up with planar glassy rectangular
displays like this example here all that
example there so what we notice is
actually that designers start embedding
computing into the environment which i
think is great but there is severely
limited by the restrictions of this
classical hardware which has been
developed for totally different purpose
initially and for what is being used now
and I think this is not doing justice to
us human beings as it restricts and
gives them a lot of the real world
switches
they've been naturally surrounded
so one line of thing that motivates my
groups research is to think about how we
can realize interfaces that instead
blend in with their physical environment
can we turn those materials here
themselves into the interface to sort of
maintain and keep up with the richness
of the classical materials that surround
us and it's led to research on
interactive materials that have been
doing together with my group now for
over five years
the key idea here is that sensing and
output capabilities are integrated
directly and seamlessly into the
material so it's being becoming an
inherent part of the material the ideas
that we have multimodal input and output
various types of input sensing the allow
the user to communicate with the
computing system and also various types
of output ideally of course I should
have a high resolution of sensing fast
for a fast response rate and allow for
computational real-time control so for
instance we can think of materials that
contain multiple functional layers or
structures and then sense touch input or
provide tactile output to the human user
we can think of materials that provide
visual output by means of seamlessly
embedded active displays these materials
can possibly deform and change shape a
computer-controlled way or they might
even interface with the human body
itself of course a key goal is that
these materials these interactive
materials blend in with a wide set of
base materials so our goal is to work
with materials that have many different
properties extremely thin materials soft
materials vegetable materials materials
cavities holes indicates fine details
pretty much any property you can think
of ideally should be supported with
interactive materials then the last
point we are sort of my perspective as a
computer scientist is blending in our
goal is that those desired properties of
interactive materials shall be desirable
using digital design tools so the idea
here is that we allow designers each
type people like us to sort of customize
the desired properties of those
materials be their shape be their
interactive behavior be either material
properties
so interactive materials or more
generally functional materials have long
been within the realm of material
science so typically you could think of
materials that are conductive or I have
many different other properties that are
available in quite complex and heavily
equipped labs in material science the
good news is that now these materials
and although these fabrication processes
are becoming available for people like
us for researchers in HCI even for
makers for interested in a people to
realize interactive materials their own
materials with their own personalized
desired custom properties in a
comparably simple lab environment so our
research on intuitive materials is part
of an emerging area as sean has
mentioned where materials intersect with
computing and different terms have been
coined in our community and elsewhere
and each of these terms and perspectives
is looking at the same problem from a
slightly different angle with the term
interactive materials we focus on HCI we
focus on the user interface on the
interaction that is happening between
the user and the computer interface that
is mitigated or mediated by materials
that our responses so how do interactive
materials change the way how people can
interact with computers the key point is
that they enable user interfaces that
are more deeply more seamlessly
integrated with new physical properties
new form factors topics such as property
such as elasticity and new locations of
us where so far it was not possible to
deploy use interface in the first place
so for instance we can think about
embedding interface in environments like
those ones here they deceive every have
rich materials be create interface with
compatible form factors and interfaces
that are aesthetic
we can think of interface DVD player on
the human body
for instance interfaces that make use of
mobility think of deploying interfaces
on when our fingertips for instant allow
us to do micro gestures while we are on
the go very subtle discreet interactions
that are compatible with eyes free eyes
for interaction depart in the body you
can think of new ways of body
interfacing for application in health in
sports or rehabilitation or we can think
of interfaces for expressive remote
communication interaction modules might
give us new ways of interacting in rich
physical ways so here for instance you
see tangibles that are fully 3d printed
on a standard FDMA 3d printer and those
tangibles can sense that information by
means of embedded capacity structures
capacitors to represent specific ways
such they detect this deformation and
the inner state of the tangible can then
be read out by a credential
off-the-shelf multi-touch sensor in this
tablet that you see underneath enriched
materials could also help us engage in
new creative ways with interactive
materials um here you see some work that
we did together with Joker resource
group a few years back it's a cuttable
multi touch sensing material the idea
here is that this is a material that one
might possibly be able to buy off the
shelf someday and then a track with this
material as if it was plain paper
essentially cut it to any desired shape
in order to make this possibly optimize
the inner routing of the electrodes and
the conductive lines inside the sensor
to ensure it is robust to a wide variety
of cuts that might occur when the sensor
is being interacted with just to give
you a last example interactive materials
have potential for education too this is
spin-off of my lab where we use foldable
electronics to help kids by means of
using simple foldable sensors to learn
about programming hardware and the
Internet of Things in a very hands-on
way so I think many exciting
opportunities for interacting with
computing devices in the future by
deeply embedding them inside the
materials and environment now in this
talk today I would like to discuss three
key questions that are becoming
important
interactive materials to HCI first how
can we create those materials those
interactive materials and I mentioned
that the classical processes and
materials that come from material
science might not be really compatible
with the environment that we need in HCI
that also might not be compatible with
the meets of rapid iterations or rapid
prototyping which is a common way of how
designers use interface designers would
explore new interface design options so
I should specify here that to be
interested in creating interactive
materials in a simple lab settings in
this lab setting that is just using
inexpensive tooling that doesn't require
complex knowledge or skills about how to
operate specific machinery or tools it
does not require to formulate or build
your own inks or materials the ideal
goal is to have an sort of off-the-shelf
setup where we use use some simple
machinery in some off-the-shelf
materials and I will show you some
examples of how this can be done a
second key question of course then from
the HCI perspective is what would be new
user interfaces and interaction
techniques that those materials with a
new properties enable of course
opportunities are manifold here I will
focus on one example area that we've
been active in for the past couple years
turning the human skin itself into an
interactive surface and into an
interface the last question that I want
to conclude with and just briefly
discuss some some work is how we can
actually support designers when they
design interactive materials I mentioned
initially that these interaction
materials can have many properties and
so it's not directly easier
straightforward to design those
properties and I will show some way of
how computers can help us do so
efficiently and effectively let's start
with the first question how can we
create interactive materials in a simple
lab setting and I will start outlining
the basic approach of how we do that
using digital fabrication then show you
one example of a touch enabled touch
display material and then briefly to do
some new works of a recent work we use
common commodity inkjet printers to do
rapid multi material fabrication on
off-the-shelf devices let's start the
basic approach so the basic idea in how
we design and realize interaction
materials is steady tivity pair some
basement
toriel with specific functional
materials so there is a wide variety of
base materials available out here and of
course our goal is to support many of
them so we work a lot with polymer or
paper or stretchable silicones but we
are also truly interested in more
exciting materials that commonly are not
or typically are not being used in user
interfaces such as wood or leather and
glass and in others then we pair those
very based materials with functional
materials that have interesting
functional properties those functional
materials TVD come from material science
they might have conductive properties
insulating properties might sense for
such imports might emit light and of
course there's many more materials that
we can use these two types of materials
are then brought together to form
together some interactive material that
has input and output capabilities and he
ever interested in many would alley is a
large variety of input and output
behavior that is important for embedded
user interfaces of course things such as
touch the sensing pressure sensing or
the formation sensing but we have also
been working on visual display tactile
or good shape change and others now the
key trick here or the key point is
actually in how you bring those base
materials together with the functional
materials there is typically specific
patterns or functional structures of how
you should lay out those materials to
get gets to a desired behavior bead
touch sensitive light-emitting or the
like so the magic is in those patterns
or functional structures and I just show
a few examples here we'll have a look at
a few of them later on these can for
instance peaches 2d arrangements of
conductive and non conductive structures
it could be 3d printed arrangements
where we combine multiple materials it
could be foldable examples like the one
who is in the right-hand side here this
is an origami like plate structure that
can be folded dynamically and senses its
interstage so the possibilities here are
endless and one of the key challenges
always to find a good structure that can
be easily fabricated with off-the-shelf
materials to realize a specific desired
behavior then the question is how do we
actually create this structure once we
know which one we would like to realize
and this is where digital fabrication
comes into play
so typically year we started a digital
design and that we realized that a
computer that is defining this very
specific pattern and then would
fabricate it we start with a digital
design tool and then use some
fabrication tools to realize the
specific structure now in terms of
fabrication tools again one can think of
a large variety of approaches that are
available we do a lot of printing
printable electronics is a very elegant
way of realizing in interactive behavior
we print on inkjet printers we do screen
printing we also use the D printing a
lot all these can be used to realize
patterns in 2d or 3d structures these
are micro machining is not approach it
comes from robotics and mechanical
engineering that allows us to party
getting broken stretchable materials I
will also show an example of all this
later
but there is much more that we commonly
do not do in our work but others do it
for instance acquainting of textile
processing I'm sewing being stitching
and others are obtaining such as spray
coating laminating they see whatever way
helps you realize those functional
structures with functional materials is
a viable approach here in terms of
fabrication what is important of course
I mentioned this before is that these
approaches here should be accessible to
HCI labs there's much more available in
material science our goal is to use the
tools and machines that we already have
in our labs labs or tools that can be
acquired for little money now to make
things a bit more concrete let me give
an example in this case we're talking
about a display material that can
realize visual output and imagine just
another concrete example you have this
artificial plant here and your goal is
for some reason of prototyping to
integrate a visual display inside this
plant sleeve could be some awarenesses
pay for instance which is giving some
information notifications to user now
it's obvious that using classical
electronics the things suitably can get
out Sparkfun would not help us here
because there's a strong incompatibility
between the form factor of those of the
shelf
hardware devices and a specific
demanding form factor they were talking
about you so our answer that we proposed
in this project print screen is to
allow the user to create his or her own
customized display materials by printing
so this allows user to realize thin-film
displays that are deformable and
actively emitting light in specific
shapes and form factors that are
compatible with those materials so the
key idea here is really that instead of
buying an off-the-shelf display you
would rather realize your own display or
have your own display printed with
specific custom properties in terms of
shape visual content etc and the way
this works is again using digital
fabrication so we start with a digital
design step where the user can draw from
a number of primitives that we have
presented in a paper for realizing
custom displays with custom visual
content those could be segments or
specific desired shapes it could be
multiple segments or even simple matrix
displays then the next step this display
is being printed and the principle that
we use here for making a display that
can actually emit light is
electroluminescence it's a known
principle for this place that our
printable and a key benefit is very
robust that means you don't need a clean
room or anything that like you can
realize it in your own simple HCI lab
environment it is essentially a light
emitting capacitor so the idea is to
bring multiple functional layers of
functional materials on top of each
other together act as a capacitor two
layers of conductors and then functional
layers typically with phosphor which
then together once you apply an AC
voltage would actively emit photons it's
and displayed is very similar to an LED
if you will but a similar one of course
we print on some basic substrate level
shows an example Seder of the materials
that you can choose from interrelate to
the top and then you have a display
which is from here a tenth of a
millimeter thick and working so how
would you print these layers of course
there's an important question for HCI
labs here we introduced function screen
printing into HCI
many of you or some of you at least I
guess will have done silkscreen printing
before probably not with functional
names just a regular leggings this we
using the very same principle here so we
can use inexpensive hobbyist equipment
for silk screen printing and then
manually apply toupees
just seen a layer by layer and this
gives you a display of a really
surprisingly high quality lastly you
connect this up in the display to
control unit and then you can interact
with it here's one example here we are
mended a classical paper postcard so
does this paper plain paper with a
static print and we augmented it with
desired visual output capabilities that
you did you see at this portions there
we used the same electrodes we print for
display also for touch sensing in a time
multiplexing way so user can actually
even interact with these displays here
in one point that motivated us to do
this project the first base is that this
approach is compatible with many
different materials you see just few of
them here I guess my favorite is wood
taking thin wood veneer and printing on
a backside allows you to have a column
display which is not visible from the
top unless it is illuminated and we this
approach many types of displays with
advanced form factors can then be
created you see some examples here
now this screamin approach works really
well with many different types of
functional materials and base materials
as we have seen but it only works with
surfaces which are planar another thing
of objects that we have around us which
tend to be more irregular nature just
principles like this stone in the photo
here in this case screen printing would
be coming to its limit in order to allow
people to print on materials that have
such irregular structures also cavities
and holes we recently proposed an
extension to screen printing which is a
water transfer process the key idea here
is to distill screen print on some
planar layer but then you did prayed on
a specific sheet that dissolves when put
onto a waterbed
which means that the print structures
essentially would be free floating on
the water surface and then you can dip
code your desired object into this
structure which then allows it to have
interactive materials that are on W
curved objects on highly irregular
objects like the ones that you see here
if you want to go one step further and
move into the inside of objects and
create some structures for whatever
reason inside objects you can use 3d
printing here's a few examples of work
that we did that I won't go into details
for reasons of time but I'm happy to
talk about those later the key idea here
is to use conductive filament alongside
normal filaments we can use standard FDM
printers which are available in most HCI
labs to realize your own specific 3d
shaped interactive materials I would
like to conclude this first part of my
talk by talking about fabrication speech
those of you who prototype interface
know how creating all iteration speed is
the first you are in your iterations the
more lo5 prototypes are middle level
fidelity prototypes you can realize and
this actually helps us in coming or
finding the final design more quickly
now the problem of the screen printing
approach they showed before and of
course also problem of 3d printing is
they takes comparing on couple hours to
realize a functional prototype
application takes that I think that the
most critical points is that you have to
expose a frame first so in order to
screen print you have
some have some negative mass that he
finds where the ink is being applied on
that surface of the material and this
takes some time we use I didn't mention
it here we use further for the front
under lithography for this purpose
there's some specific emulsion and then
you apply each Lea manually you have to
try you have to do two heat curing also
all takes time together if you're fast
them you can win in two hours but it
could even take longer than that so one
approach that is considerably faster is
this one here this is not from our own
habits from Yoshihiro cava Hara from the
University of Tokyo really pioneering
work he showed a very exciting property
of desktop inkjet printers which is you
can essentially buy an off-the-shelf
ancient printer refill it with some
specific conductive server ring and then
you can print flexible circuits within
minutes just as help others help others
in the community a lot to realize
interfaces much more rapidly great touch
sensor as flexible PCBs even antenna
within minutes but a limitation of this
approach is that it's restricted to only
one specific type of cell few specific
types of substrate materials which are
comparable a thick little bit like pet
films or photo paper good for many
applications but limited for others for
instance we need stretch ability and
it's also really restricted to only a
single layer of server ink which limits
use for many of the applications that we
use screen printing firm and so now I'm
excited to share the first time in
public some new work which is not
published yet where we actually extended
this approach and allow people to use
off-the-shelf inkjet printers to realize
multi-layer multi-material circuits so
be considerably enhanced in a set of
materials that can be printed with and a
set of substrates you can print on for
instance now you can use vegetable
substrates ultra slim soft substrates
and others alongside a conventional
inkjet printer and I will just show a
video that shows how this works so use
an off-the-shelf inkjet printer which
costs roughly 50 50 bucks and fill in
specific types of ink so the
nanoparticle in life in prior work but
also conductive polymer in which is
highly stretchable electrically
isolating ink and graphical inks and
cell types of these inks
learned on the same printer to be used
simultaneously many of these things can
even be braided on together in a single
pass and so for instance in this example
here this allows you to realize
conductive structures with selective
striated electrical insulation on top so
for instance you could realize patterned
electrodes or parent op connectors using
this approach here very easily it also
allows her to realize full-color about
service and Bend on many different
materials so for instance he is he hi
nice vegetable substrates that can be
stretched by roughly 50% for soft
interfaces we have a transfer approach
to realize circuits textiles we as ultra
slim tattoo designs or work with
thermoplastics so this is considerably
extending the range of materials that
you can work with another set of
applications that are being possible for
instance you could realize your own
stretchable you know input devices
within minutes your own et textile
circuits within minutes or even
interface with the human body these are
all things that we use three pinning
before again I mentioned to a couple
hours now we brought this down to two
minutes and this required a quite
extensive careful matching of the inks
with the substrate materials and a
printer to get just working so the next
question I want to talk about is
actually how we can grade or what types
of use interface we can create and what
are the interaction techniques and of
course opportunities are manifold I
essentially would like just to highlight
as a two main areas where you can do
this in the environment or of many the
human and it's the letter that your
partically first made about because skin
is such an interesting material it is
soft it is vegetable it's carrying all
our body the skin is inherently
multimodal sensitive and expressive it
supports proprioception detection many
other of the exciting features and
properties that we are using on an
everyday basis looking at the history of
mobile computing devices
skin may well be the next interface so
if you look at each of these generations
we noticed that
with each generation the devices get
smaller the form factor is considerably
decreased at the same time those devices
are moving closer to the human body so
this makes it plausible for us at least
that skin might be the next generation
of interfaces that are intimately really
closely coupling and this led us to work
on a vision that we call interactive
skin where the ideas that we create very
very slim devices that contain sensors
displays actuators that you can be a
ride on your skin even a very demanding
body locations such as those here that
are highly curved and undergo a lot of
strain and deformation so for instance
the blood the fingertips these devices
could allow us to do new types of
ice-free ice-free micro gestures the
idea is that we have high resolution
multimodal input and output on those
devices could possibly even interface
with the body for purposes such as
physiological sensing and the point that
here again is very important that I
mentioned before and the other examples
as well is that there is a high degree
of personalization necessary probably
even higher in this case than with off
body applications so the size and shape
of those devices varies quite a bit
amongst users and so that's the visual
aesthetics so as soon as fiber devices
on our body they become sort of a
fashion statement if you will and each
and every user probably has a different
understanding of how devices should look
like on their own body so within the
space I would like to present three
projects that we have done in the past
years
first about personalized skin interfaces
how we realize those personalized shapes
and visual aesthetics then secondly I'm
going to talk about you interaction
using body landmarks and lastly
mentioned some some recent work that
represented with last year about feel
through tactile out but I should say
that a key motivation for interactive
skin is work from the robotics community
in mechanical engineering community
about electronic skin so the main idea
here is and I started as early as 20
years ago with this idea is to augment
robots with some skin type behavior or
skin type surface that can sense
surface interactions or environmental
interactions and a lot of work has been
done since in in those communities for
robots but also for the human skin
draw hundreds materials also upon the
fabrication processes that have been
presented here but again a specific
perspectives that we have is that we
transfer brooches to make them viable
within an HDI context so I would like to
start with ice cream this is worked at
this end of years back at Kai which is
an approach for realizing personalized
skin interfaces that have personalized
shapes and personalized aesthetics it's
the the first vegetable touch sensor for
the human skin that was presented and
here's an example of a prototype we make
this off silicone materials that are
highly stretchable and deformable as you
can see here and this device is sent
sense touch input at various desired
locations with two levels of contact
force in order to make those devices
customizable we again use a digital
fabrication pipeline start with silicone
type materials PDMS is a medical grade
silicone and see PDMS is a very end of
that where carbon particles have been
added to make the structure unproductive
the designer can lay out a digital
design in a custom shape in custom
aesthetics and I would like to highlight
that the black parts that you see here
actually are both the visual design at
the same time they also act as the
electrical connections as the electrodes
that are required for sensing and as the
interconnect and using some principles
that we presented a paper these can be
laid out in specific visually aesthetic
ways but then you use that laser cutter
for pattern those layers and sandwich
those together to realize a five layer
sandwich that uses capacitive and
resistive sensing for detecting touch
input and this allows for realizing new
types of body devices just a few
examples are shown here for instance
device that can be wrapped around a
finger for micro gestures you could
think of stickers that are really
inexpensive could act as a giveaway at a
festival if you will one couldn't
realize extensions to conventional
devices which are soft in this case or
we have realized that roll out keyboard
I think this is just one example for a
larger class of devices that are soft
and extended rigid body one accessories
and of course there's many more
applications you can think of
now looking at I skin I should mention
that the devices that we have realized
he was silicon are roughly half a
millimeter thick which is fairly thin
compared to the classical devices but
still comparable thick if you think of
the human skin essentially what I skin
dude is looking at a skin a little bit
in a way of that illustration that we
see here between the skin as maybe a
slightly curved surface but which is
more or less homogeneous now of course
if you look more closely at our human
body we notice there's many more
features we go down to the details
so there's many features that are
visually this thing from the
surroundings as features that are
actually distinct from their
surroundings any follow-up work we were
interested in leveraging on those to
realize interfaces that most seamlessly
blend with the human body and
particularly to allow the user to sort
of identify them identify distinct areas
on the body for interaction by being
guided by those body landmarks
now this required us to realize devices
that are much slimmer and for this
purpose we used a different approach we
used screen printing on commercially
available temporary tattoo paper here's
one example of a print screen like
electroluminescent display that we
realized in a very slim form factor so
it can be wall on the body and deforms
closely in nicely with the human skin in
addition to displace realize other
modalities to touch input of course
capacitive touch boot is comparable easy
but we also realized squeeze sensors
that make use of the elasticity of the
human skin and Bend sensors that can
detect the physical configuration of the
body the important part here that I
would like to highlight is that those
devices are much slimmer than the
devices we had before you see
photographs on the top that showed that
these devices closely conformed even to
find wrinkles on the body and these
seams can be no he'll show us that his
devices depending on how many layers
they have would range between 4 microns
and roughly 50 microns which is still
thinner than the diameter of a typical
human hair not if you have devices that
are so closely conforming to the human
body this allows us to interact on body
landmarks we dived in the literature and
identified a number of landmarks that we
can use can be used for interaction
making use of bony skeletal features for
instance making use of micro structures
elasticity in others
I'm gonna show some of the example
interaction techniques that we have
presented in the paper there is more
interested you can find them in the
paper and in the full video one example
that I'm excited about is
microstructures if you think of a human
hand there's many of them those tiny
flexure lines that we have and they have
this really interesting property that
you can feel them with visiting your
thumb sliding across the index finger
you can feel them even without looking
at it so this makes it a good way of
providing tactile feedback for micro
gestures say while you're on the go and
you cannot look at the area where you're
interacting in this example here we use
those flexure lines for intolerant input
turning some functionality on and off by
deploying a touch sensor on this lecture
line which is very slim and then you see
essentially here that this can be used
to tunnel features on off and give me if
many of those flexure lines on the data
hands we can think of many different
types of functionalities are laid out on
the hand for direct interactions now if
you do not toggle but instead you slide
in the orthogonal direction we can think
of this as a continuous slider so in
this case here it could be said setting
some continuous value while you were
inside along and again here we leveraged
on texture and proprioception to allow
the user to get direct tectile feedback
about his or her interaction via visual
landmarks such as birthmarks when can
think of ways to augment natural visual
landmarks with some other type of visual
output in this case this could be used
for self expression of a remote
communication just one example that
shows that slim body wall displays are
viable using this technology when last
exam I would like to show is elastic
landmarks here the ideas that we allow
the user to make use of the inherent
variability of the body for different
types of interactions different than
touching in this case here we use the
squeezed censored allows the user at a
loss system to detect squeezing or
pulling and this commuters some form of
input for instance to avoid false
positives because it is likely that you
accidentally accidentally pulling on
some specific area on the skin
so now that I've shown the basic
feasibility of interactive skin in some
exam interaction techniques there is one
important channel missing you may have
noticed this I have not not talked about
tactile output so far which of course is
a prime modality an interaction channel
when we talk about the human body
so can we integrate tectile output
inside a tattoo form factor that was one
of the question that has trained us for
a couple years and I would log like to
show you some project knowledge shows
that this is possible so this allows us
to realize new types of interfaces in
tactile augmented reality let me explain
what I mean by that so if you look at
the visual domain for instance we have
devices like the hololens these allow us
to augment real-world visual cues with
computer-generated visual output we have
something similar for hearing on
conducting headphones for instance they
keep our natural hearing intact so we
can hear that natural auditory cues from
the environment at the same time we can
augment them with some
computer-generated output but how about
the tactile domain how about a few 3
interface say an interface that in this
case would allow us to feel the rubbery
features of the tire and at the same
time of many with computer-generated
output obviously it will not work with
an actuator it is like this one here
because it's too rigid and too bulky to
address this problem we have realized
tag tool which is the first feel so
tactile interface it is considerably
slimmer so actually you can feel through
the interface itself while of mending it
with computer-generated tactile awkward
it's an ATAR to form factor to our
knowledge the fitness tactile interface
available so far with 35 moments of
thickness and so you can see on this
photo here it's conformal even with tiny
wrinkles it features a high Texel
density for tactile output and given we
use again digital fabrication it's
easily customizable so these are my left
is on the finger pad the example on the
right is on the form with these any
features how to talk to enables to
augment physical objects or the human
body with tactile output it can also
live a subtle and private notifications
to the skin as Miss example here and
it's ten stacks IRA can create rich
haptic sensations for for we our
experiences so this insatiable basic
just nice transition lead over to the
next slide
so the sensation is sort of a vibration
or slightly so we actually looked into
many different technologies because
obviously it's the mind to realize
technological device which is
thirty-five migrants sick and we
eventually opted for electro tactile
output so the key benefit of electro
text output is that you don't need
mechanical actuators which tend to be
more bulky by Nature all you need is an
electrode and then basically you you you
send some slight current into the skin
which is stimulating nerve endings and
this can be felt as a slight vibration
or slice tickling it's an on principle
has been applied before but never in a
device form factor which is as thin and
it brings me to the challenge that we
had to solve actually need to deliver a
certain amount of current one to 2 milli
amperes in this case food or skin
exposed elements and so skin contact is
a really critical point here if you need
to have strong and consistent skin
contact to consistently deliver this
current if there were just some tiny air
gaps sparks might arise that render the
electrodes
it's not painful but it renders the
electrodes unusable and I have an
example here from prior work at chi that
shows this very effect here happening so
after some use of the electrodes on left
you see how it initially looked like on
the right hand side you see there the
effect of those tiny sparks that have
happened and so we wanted to realize the
system that despite the very slim design
with small mechanical forces that we can
apply despite those properties is really
closely and strongly contacting to human
skin and to this end we created a
printable approach to ensure tights a
tight fitting of the device by printing
an approach that we call my crispy the
key idea here is that we leverage on
multiple functional materials that have
different physical capabilities I mean
different thicknesses once they are
printed so we've been part of the tattoo
probably all the electrical
interconnects
with an electrically conductive polymer
which is called PPSS and this can be
printed in very very thin lines in
contrast we print the electrodes that
are contacting the human skin with
silver and silver print electrodes if
your screen printing are much thicker
then the Peter PSS printed printed lines
so actually what we have is what you see
on that right inside we have this
electrodes are roughly 20 microns thick
while a remainder is much less thick
roughly 8 microns and so this has an
interesting effect once you transfer
this printing device onto the body what
actually happens is that the the soft
areas stretch and it creates some
lateral tension which then in turn
translates into some normal force and
this actually generates some slight
force which is strong enough to create a
consistent skin contact this is example
I'm here again so the one of the very
right hand side is our micro screen
mechanism even after use we have a clean
clear electrodes in contrast if we use
the very same stack of materials that we
have but without printing the micro
spring mechanism ours would look like in
Prior work which is showing this problem
of deterioration that you might have
because of air gaps so this is a very
principle and with this we were able to
create good and significant lasting
contact of course we're interested
whether these devices really feel
through I don't want to go into details
here they are in the paper but the
bottom line is the perception of wearing
this device is close to not wearing a
device at all those severe skin and
another important point is it's
considerably better than the priority of
the art which was so roughly a 100
micron thick device so what we see here
is that even quinn's every small
improvements if you will or either
micron level here have important effects
on the variability in the field through
properties of those devices to look into
these questions in more detail we have
recently published study it guided how
just extended findings about how
different types of materials of these
epidermal devices affect human tactile
perception now these field properties of
taku then allow us to realize novel
kinds of interfaces coming back to the
example that I've shown previously in
this case a designer working on a model
can now feel a real rubbery texture of
the original car well we can augment it
with say for instance simulated engine
vibrations on the human body we can use
this device to provide dynamic output
dynamic landmarks in addition to the
steady ones that I talked about before
so the user can still feel bony
structures or veins on a knife for being
guided but then we can also dynamically
render virtual buttons if you will for
instance on the device that might even
be reacting on to being touched or
pressure with a different pattern and
then finally the dense array of talk to
allows us to create rich tactile
sensations we are in this example for
instance here a virtual branch that is
rendered in VR the user can feel the
needles or the stems and branches in a
sort of localized way by basically
having actually only one text so while
if you're touching larger areas we would
set how many more of these texels
activated so actually can create some
some rich novel ways of experience
experiencing the virtual reality here so
let me to the end of my talk I would
like to conclude with a third area
briefly talking about how we can
actually support designing for those
interactive materials and I think you
have seen now in the previous examples
that interactive materials have many
different properties that might be hard
to design for actually so we talked
about material properties here say for
instance it is a stretch ability of
those materials we're talking about the
shape it could be 2d contour also more
complicated 3d shapes and of course last
but not least the interactive behavior
what sort of sensing or aqua modalities
shall be supported what's the
interactive location the resolution we
could even think of user interface
controls that encapsulate some specific
type of behavior now designing for all
of them is of course not easy and the
way we have done this so far is
essentially doing a manual design using
a digital design tool so by laying odds
circuitry in a vector graphics
application by writing arduino firmware
code etc that's something we can do and
I think many other people user community
can do so the experience that these
approaches work well
community but it's understood there is
still sort of a high high entry level
for for end users or for designers who
are less familiar with electronics and
so to support those I think an important
next step will be to provide
computational design tools so these
abstract from those low level details
and sort of allow the designer to
specify the desired high level
properties and then the ideas that these
design tools will generate low level
designs for fabrication print files STL
files and the like and they might also
provide controller code or even stops
for the final application to interface
with so combinational design tools is
not a novel field there has been quite a
bit of work particularly in the computer
graphics applications committed graphics
domain but typically they look at
geometry or some some function
properties relating to it with geometry
and materials being in contrast here
look basic yet electronics so our goal
is to bring a specific electronic design
together with specific materials now
what we just want to show a few first
examples from our recent work for each
of these areas of course all of them are
interlinked so in this case here we
design for specific material properties
but of course we also have to take shape
into consideration and the electronics
so this is LASIK work that we have
presented this year at KY and the key
idea here is to provide a very rapid way
to create stretchable circuits and a
novelty here is that this stretch
ability can be custom designed so you
can basically design while you design a
circuit house vegetable should be what
is it directionality of stretch and you
can even have multiple areas several
areas defined on the same circuit we do
this using parametric cut patterns that
you can see here then allow some
deformability riyals to stretch once
these cut patterns our plight and here's
an example of the interface the designer
specifies a desired stretchable area and
convinced that a stretch ability using a
slider as you can see now it is
automatically dynamically adapts the
pattern then to to
and this vegetable material into a
circuit the user can select components
from a library of components place them
on the circuits and then define how they
shall be electrically connected and then
the designer will take care of the rest
and automatically create routings
through this complex cut pattern here a
laser compatible specification is then
automatically realized and then in a
single pass on a laser cutter using
cutting and ablation this vegetable
circuit can be realized within just a
few minutes and this allows you to
realize prototypes like this one here
very simple one this one here that uses
multiple directional ease of stretch
integrated a stretchable sensor for the
elbow here again we use multiple levels
of stretch ability or this simple
prototype here where we have a
stretchable gain controller where the
special part in the middle is actually
powered a circuit and electrically
connecting between both handles going
one step up looking at shape another
example here on multi touch sensors
worked at presented last year at Chi
talking about shape of course in our
case again means that we have to adapt
the electronic circuitry to meet with
the specific demands of those shapes
this is what we did here in this example
of a multi-touch sensor here with this
design totally you know the designer
just specifies the desired outer corner
of the sensor and then using parametric
designs the actual functional elements
of the sensor are automatically realized
in a very last example for the highest
level interactive behaviour this one
here in this case this is folio we
supported a or presented a new
fabrication technique for creating
folded 3d objects that are interactive
and the key idea here is to abstract
from low-level foldable patterns to high
level user interface controls because it
would be really difficult for designers
or end users to specify specific
patterns anything about electrodes and
the like should be laid out there so all
this has taken care carry out by the by
the tool and so we give what we
developed is various parametric user
interface controls that can be directly
applied to a 3d model this is all in
blender or a CAD modeling environment
then essentially they just show up here
and I will show in a video here what is
T behavior and basically by selecting
those print
controls and applying him to the 3d
geometry they automatically
parameterised and then displayed here is
unfallen view so although that the
routings and all those parts would be
done automatically which gives us the
end of print specification that can
simply be printed for fabrication and
this allows user to very rapidly
prototype foldable for the objects such
as this interactive lampshade there is
touch-sensitive or a fun game controller
which is bendable or print activators in
a very slim that I integrate inside
those 3d structures here just my
favorite a paper plane which is slide
enough to fly and as a display embedded
so of course these are just first and in
simple examples there's a lot more work
to be done in this space here and I
think one of the key questions is what
are the appropriate user interface
controls or the appropriate levels of
abstraction that we can offer to
designers so they can make productive
use of interactive materials for for
embedding interfaces so this means been
to the conclusion I hope today I could
convince you that interactive materials
are no longer restricted to material
science they are now entering the realm
of HCI and we can start making
productive use of those so we have
fabrication techniques available that
are easy to use and affordable and also
wrap it so we can embed a wide variety
of input and output modalities into a
wide range of materials we have seen
others new form factors and material
properties enable promising novel
interactive devices interaction
techniques I've mostly focused just on
the body today but research from other
groups is showing exciting other avenues
of how you can integrate such
interaction materials inside a wide
array of interactive applications then
last but not least I highlighted the
need for computational support even need
more research that allows design
designers for end users to use
computational design to us to learn to
model in a at a high level of
abstraction so what are the reactions
for future work alongside the line of
design tools I think president is a
really important aspect they were just
starting to tap upon so what works
fairly well now for interface
seiners doesn't necessarily work well
yet for end-users and one reason is that
one day end users can base just get say
the body scanned and then a
correlational design tool would
automatically realize a personalized
medical device say for instance for them
that they can have printed as a service
like your photo book to me today at some
point they might even bring it on their
own desk using some inexpensive device
that they have at home
realizing self-contained systems is
another important Avenue so essentially
all of the prototypes that have shown
here are connected to some still rich in
microcontroller a rigid battery that is
then wellesley connecting to computing
device realizing self-contained systems
that harvest their own energy or create
their own energy by interaction is an
orthogonal question that is being worked
on in our community and elsewhere and
really important to bring together with
the research that we're doing here and
then lastly I'm really excited about the
opportunities that the human body is
providing for future user interfaces
I've shown one example where we use
interactive skin to interface with the
human body electrically but this is just
the starting point there's many more
opportunities for using interactive
materials for various applications in
health and fitness in rehabilitation etc
so of course many people have
contributed to the projects that I've
presented today and I would like to
thank all of them all my team members
who have contributed to these projects
and also external collaborators and MIT
at CMU Google these sort of new
materials to Darmstadt and the
University of Copenhagen thank you
you